Specifically, if we have a
column vector v like this, which we assume has
complex number entries, alpha one through alpha n,
then the Euclidean norm of v is defined like you see right here.
This is the notation we
use for the Euclidean norm putting these double bars around whatever vector we're talking about.
In this case, it's v, and the way the Euclidean norm is defined is that it's the square root of the sum
of the absolute values squared
of the entries of the vector.
So another way to define what
a quantum state vector is is that a quantum state vector is a column vector having
complex number entries
whose Euclidean norm is equal to one, which is to say that it's a unit vector with respect to the Euclidean norm.
That's because the sum of
the absolute value squared is equal to one if and only if the Euclidean
norm is equal to one.
The square root doesn't change anything when the sum of the absolute
values squared is equal to one.
So that's what a quantum state vector is. It's a column vector with indices that correspond to the
classical states of a system
having complex number entries and Euclidean norm equal to one.
What that means or what it implies or how we should interpret this
notion is a different matter and in some sense,
the study of quantum
information and computation is an exploration of what
this definition implies, at least, in terms of
information processing.
This is simply the starting point.
As an aside, let me mention that there
are other so-called norms besides the Euclidean norm and this notation right
here with the double bars
around a vector doesn't always
mean the Euclidean norm.
In different contexts, this notation could refer
to a different norm.
For example, the sum
of the absolute values with no squares or square
root is a different norm,
often called the one norm. There are quite a lot of
different norms, in fact.
Sometimes you'll see
this notation being used with a subscript after
the second set of bars that provides more information about what norm we're talking about.
And when we do that, it's pretty typical that the number two as a subscript
means the Euclidean norm.
But in this series, whenever we have a
column vector like this, this double bar notation all by itself
means the Euclidean norm.
Here are a few examples
of quantum state vectors and these particular quantum state vectors are qubit state vectors,
which means that the
classical states of our system are zero and one.
The word qubit is short for quantum bit, which is really just a bit
that can be in a quantum state.
The first two examples are really simple. The standard basis vectors
ket zero and ket one are quantum state vectors.
They're both column vectors, and the indices correspond
to the classical states is zero and one, and the entries of these
vectors are complex numbers.
For these particular vectors, the entries are zero and one, which are real numbers, and in fact, they're integers, but they're also complex numbers
that happen to have
imaginary part equal to zero.
Each vector has one entry equal to one and one entry equal to zero.
So when we sum the absolute
values of the entries, we get one in both cases.
So the conditions
required for these vectors to be quantum state vectors are satisfied.
The next two examples are very commonly encountered qubit states called the plus state and the minus state.
They're denoted as you
see here on the screen, either with a ket plus
or a ket minus like this, and they're defined as
you can see right here.
Again, the entries of these
vectors are complex numbers. This time, they're either positive one over square root of two or negative one over square root of two,
and when we sum the
absolute values squared, we get 1/2 plus 1/2, which is one.
By the way, putting a
plus sign or a minus sign inside of a ket like this
might seem a little strange because these aren't classical
states of our system,
but this notation is used nevertheless, and we'll come back to this momentarily.
But for now, in short, we can use the Dirac notation to put whatever name we want for a vector inside of a ket.
The vector doesn't have to
be a standard basis vector when we use the Dirac notation.
Here's a final qubit state
example for the moment, anyway.
It's a quantum state vector of a qubit that doesn't have a special name, and it's not particularly significant.
The entries of this vector are one plus two times i
over three and negative 2/3.
These are complex numbers, and if you compute the
absolute values squared of these two entries, you'll get 5/9 for the first one
and 4/9 for the second one. So the sum of the absolute
value squared is equal to one.
And here's one last example. This time for a system
whose classical states are the four card suits.
I don't know why we would have a system whose classical states
are the four card suits being in a quantum state, but it is possible in principle
and it's just meant as an example.